- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
Have y'all met before?
- Yes!
- We have.
- It's been a while.
- Love you.
- Thank you.
- You're amazing too, oh my goodness.
- Was your mom a teacher, did I hear?
- Yes, she was, she was a teacher.
- [Kelly] Did she ever teach you?
- Yeah, all the time, yeah.
My dad was a psychologist,
my mom a teacher.
So that was weird when I got a spanking.
'Cause I would get a spanking by my mom
and then my dad would
go, "How did you feel
"about that spanking?
(group laughs)
"How was it?"
- Oh my God.
I would love when my
parents would be like,
it'd be like this hurts
me more and it hurts you.
I'm like, well turn around!
Lets see.
- Turn around.
- Let's just, I mean,
might as well try it out.
So wait, your new book, this
is called 'Blessed Mode.'
- [Kel] Yes, exciting!
- [Kelly] So what made
you want to do this?
- What made me wanna do it?
This is really a book to let everyone know
that in every emotional wall,
there is a divine breakthrough, right?
- [Kelly] Oh interesting.
- And a lot of people are
going through a lot of things
in their lives,
that we don't know about.
- Especially the last two years.
- Yeah.
And I want this book to be a positive way
where they can get up in the morning
and connect with God
and let them know that they are blessed.
They were blessed when they were born.
You know?
And that's what it's all about, yeah.
- [Kelly] Blessed you're still here.
- Yeah.
Blessed that you're still here.
Stay blessed, you are loved.
(audience claps)
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Angela claps)
(audience claps)
- Did you ever...
But it's a 90 day thing, right?
- Yeah.
- So it's like, that's cool.
So it's like every day you kind
of have something in there?
- Well, it's a devotional.
- I love that.
- And a lot of my ups
and downs in my life,
God was always there.
For me.
And I wanted to show people what I do,
so that I can get into a positive mindset.
And it works on your mental health,
your spiritual health
and your physical health.
Yeah, so I start you
off with a Bible verse,
short story about my life.
And then I take you through a prayer
and then my favorite part is called,
'Go Get Them Blessings'.
Where you apply it to your life.
So I might have you forgive somebody.
Or I might have you do a burpee.
You know what I mean?
- Oh a burpee.
(Kel shouts)
- It's physical health.
- I'll forgive people, I
don't wanna do a burpee.
That's (indistinct).
(Kel laughs)
Awesome.
- Yeah.
- So wait, so you talk about your struggle
with addiction right?
In this?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
That's awesome that you're
opening up about that
because that's really hard.
I have a few friends actually.
Do you feel like faith is really what
pulled you through?
- Definitely.
It's like depression is
just like frustration,
that we just keep inside, you know?
And no one can understand.
No one can understand
what I'm going through.
And you don't want to talk about it.
And I did that a lot.
And then I went to substance
abuse and things of nature
to try to cover it up.
But then when I realized like, no, no, no,
I don't wanna cover this up anymore.
I want to actually forgive myself-
- [Kelly] Shine a light on it.
- Forgive others and shine a light on it.
Yeah.
And actually talk about it.
And when I decided to do that
and connect more with God,
you know what I mean?
And connect on that level.
Everything started to
change around for me.
It took a journey, but
you know, in the Bible
it says renew your mind daily.
And so that's very important
that we renew our mind
all the time.
'Cause this mind is like a disc.
It keeps everything, you know what I mean?
And you get reminded of like mistakes
in the past,
things that people-
- [Kelly] All the little voices.
- Yeah.
But that's why it's so important to get up
and just know like, no, no, no.
I was made for a purpose.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I have a purpose today, you know?
- Yeah.
I unfortunately have had like
a few people die very young,
in my life, around me.
And it's one of those things
where I wake up every day
and I'm just like thankful to wake up.
I'm like not everybody
gets that opportunity.
Like even if you're having like hard time,
'cause I've also suffered from depression.
And I can go zero dark 30.
And so it's one of those
things where I think
that faith really helped me as well.
Does faith help you at all?
- Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, I grew up in the
family of faith and I mean,
that's my family that's, you know,
thankful to my mother
and I'm like you say,
this career,
I came from just very, very humble
and to have a dream,
but to also know there's
something greater than you;
'cause you have those
moments and those days,
and those things that come against you.
You gotta know that you
can make it through.
You know it's so, like you
say renew your mind daily.
The word says you're
fearfully wonderfully made.
It also says think on these things.
You don't think of what's
good, what's positive.
That's full of joy.
Think on those things.
Because the battlefield is the mind.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- [Kel] That's right.
Amen.
- And it's making sure
you're surrounding yourself
with people that have that kind
of positive energy as well.
And it's so funny.
Whatever you believe in;
there's a lot of beliefs out there.
But it's one of those things where
I find it so hard to believe.
I'm like, I can't imagine.
I think what would've killed me,
would've been not believing that anything,
like any other bigger purpose for us.
You know what I'm saying?
There's nothing...
I have to feel like we're
all a part of something,
whatever your spiritual belief is,
that we're all all a part of something
that's bigger than us.
Like I don't know.
I just feel like it's
a very egocentric thing
to not think that.
But-
- So true.
- But that could be humanity
run amuck right there.
But you are a blessed man and
this is a really, really cool-
- Appreciate it.
- [Kelly] Thing to do, not just for you,
but for other people
- For other people,
that's what it's about.
- [Kelly] That's really, really cool.